the humanitarian crisis on europe's
eastern flank shows no sign of easing
poland is pushing back multiple groups
of migrants trying to get over the
border from belarus those who make it
across mostly young families from iraq
are left to face harsh winter conditions
out in the open
now local polish residents are rallying
around to help dw's amnesia reports
[Applause]
a person's place is not in the woods
they shout mothers from around poland
have come to the border region near
belarus to show their concern for the
crisis unfolding here at least a dozen
migrants have died in the forest just
kilometers away a number of them on the
polish side of the border
one of the latest victims was a
one-year-old child
this is so close to our home yes it's
only three hours
by the vicarious from from warsaw and
how can i say to my kids that some other
kids are
frozen
in the forest yes and we are not helping
them
i'm from the south so it took me like
seven hours to come here
but this is my first protest i've ever
taken part of so this is something that
i need i felt that i need to speak about
and it needs to be said
some mothers traveled here in a bus
bringing with them supplies and
gratitude for the local volunteers
helping save lives in the woods
one of these volunteers is monica
tworkovska she lives near the border and
local residents can often provide help
where aid agencies are banned
she found a volunteer network online and
joined just a few days ago
in my opinion it's not about just
letting everybody in
we have different agencies to verify all
of these people let them do this
and we as a people we as a country our
volunteer and all of our different
humanitarian organizations should be
allowed to go in and to help
we cannot let those people die in the
woods when they are freezing hungry
thirsty sick
this is not humane
the polish government says that if it
were to welcome the migrants with open
arms this would play into the hands of
belarus's alleged plan to destabilize
the eu
but it's clear that this hardline policy
has had casualties and more tragedy is
sure to come as winter approaches
and our correspondent amy nassif joins
me now from hinovka on the polish side
of the border amin why is it easier for
locals to help the migrants hiding in
the forest than it is for aid
organizations for example
well nick poland has essentially built a
second border around its real border
with belarus
there's checkpoints along the road so
that people can't get in people like
journalists civil society but local
residents can pass through if they live
on the other side or if they have an id
showing that they live in the area then
there's lighter restrictions on them
going into the restricted area and out
of the restricted area
as i said
as a journalist we have not been allowed
into this
restricted zone and that goes for aid
organizations as well like the red cross
and the un uh uh refugee commission
so
local activists are just i wouldn't even
call them activists just local
volunteers people who have seen the
headlines seen that people are dying in
the woods have uh taken up uh the flag
and have
tried to go in there and just provide
any aid they can so as we saw in the
report monica who's never done anything
like this before she's now thrown into a
situation where she's having to deal
with media she's having to deal
with
people claiming asylum going in between
lawyers and border patrol and
migrants who are in the hospital
so she's overwhelmed but she says that
this is something that she couldn't just
let happen on her doorstep
yeah and i think you know
watching those mothers you could hear
the compassion and
anger as well i think in in their voices
uh
clearly moved by the idea of children
having to spend the night
in the forest and occasionally you know
some some of them even freezing to death
do you think
that feeling is going to spread through
polish society are these protests
changing how how the population is
feeling
i think for sure the protests are an
indication that the uh the polish are
seeing this a little bit differently
than they did a few weeks ago and that's
because the situation has changed at
least how it's being reported so in the
beginning of the crisis poland's uh hard
their line was that the humanitarian
crisis was happening only on the
belarusian side and that was more true a
few weeks ago than it is now because uh
lukashenko has ordered that the camps be
evacuated along the border a lot of
those uh migrants who are trying to get
into poland have been brought to
shelters and only trying to cross at
night so what you see now is that this
double border this no ago zone on the
polish border on the polish side of the
border has become an open-air prison for
people who have crossed the fence but
have not yet been picked up by police
and that's where we're seeing a lot of
the recent deaths happening including a
one-year-old child last week so i think
these headlines have started to change
opinion and that's why you saw this
protest this wasn't a protest that's
been long organized by long-established
aid groups and activists this was
something that really brought mothers
from around the country we talked to
people from krakow people from warsaw
and also people from the local area and
i think we can understand the reasons
for their mobilization very dramatic and
tragic pictures you've been sharing with
us thank you eminencif in high norfolk
poland